après trois mois de mission l'état-major
fait le pari de la transparence
les soldats canadiens ont bel et bien dû
se défendre en irak fait le commandant
des forces d'opérations spéciales
concède que ses hommes ont dû riposter
après avoir affronté les tirs ennemis
les forces spéciales canadiennes
accompagnaient l'armée irakienne pour
planifier une offensive contre le groupe
armé l'état islamique
ils ont dû essuyer de puissants tirs les
forces canadiennes ont donc dû
neutraliser l'ennemi c'est la seul
incident si vous voulez où nous on est
échangé le feu avec à essence est la
seule fois que c'est arrivé incident
isolé martèle la défense nationale qui
ne change pas la donne sur le terrain
par le fait qu'on a eu un échange de
frida kahlo veut pas dire que c'est
devenu une mission de corbas c'est
beaucoup plus nuancée qu'à ça pourtant
fin septembre en plein débat sur la
nature du rôle des forces spéciales en
irak
est ce qu'ils font des sorties en zone
de combat le premier ministre répétait
que le rôle des canadiens se limitait à
conseiller et assister les forces
irakiennes les soldats canadiens
des forces irakiennes dans leurs rivaux
or de l'aveu même de l'état-major la
semaine dernière les canadiens étaient
bel et bien au front c'est du combat
pour cet expert en sécurité
internationale au joue sur les mots sur
les lignes de combat peut y avoir des
combats et sont ici sont armés si
utilisé leurs armes même une autre
défense selon moi on a dépassé la ligne
du combat maintenant là appelez ça comme
vous voulez ce n'est pas ce que le
premier ministre avait promis aux
canadiens affirme le npd marqué ce que
ce développement risquent de marquer un
tournant dans la mission canadienne là
bas c'est au bureau du premier ministre
se soit on dit que ça ne change rien que
ça ne change pas la nature de la mission
que la définition d'euros de combat et
bien c'est d'affronter physiquement
agressivement et directement l'ennemi
donc d'initier l'affrontement cela dit
le problème pour le gouvernement c'est
que sous le prétexte du secret
opérationnel et bien il n'a jamais voulu
parler de ce que les militaires allaient
vraiment faire en irak donc ce
développement vient en quelque sorte
jeter un éclairage si vous voulez sur le
rôle précis des conseillers militaires
canadiens et c'est ce flou quand retenu
le gouvernement qui vient aujourd'hui le
rattraper malgré les questions ciblées
l'opposition jour après jour lors du
débat sur la question l'automne dernier
ça va inévitablement alimenté les
discussions sur tout les hauts gradés
sont allés jusqu'à dire aujourd'hui que
la coalition a carrément freiner l'état
islamique en irak où l état major a par
ailleurs clairement indiqué que la
bataille contre l'état islam et pourrait
durer très longtemps est ce que ça veut
dire que l'engagement initial du canada
c'était de six mois risquent d'être plus
longs maintenant tout ça va certainement
été le débat sur un éventuel
prolongement ou non de l'émission dont
l'échéance je vous le rappelle arrive au
mois d'avril
encore aujourd'hui on l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises ça va prendre des
années avant de gagner cette bataille
mais au delà du débat policé que je vous
dirais que la défense nationale
aujourd'hui a tenu à préciser que si
jamais les militaires devaient rester là
bas
et bien qu'ils seraient prêts à le faire
très bien merci beaucoup marque au
revoir